nous sommes donc retrouvés pour un
conseil européen
dans la première partie s'est tenue cet
après midi qui se poursuivra demain dans
la matinée et qui nous a permis pour les
heures qui viennent de s'écouler de
poursuivre l'effort de coordination que
nous avons engagée sur la lutte contre
le virus
s'agissant de la situation actuelle nous
nous sommes accordés sur l'urgence de la
lutte contre les variantes du virus et
avons soutenu le lancement par la
commission d'une sorte de barda
européenne era qui va réunir laboratoire
chercheurs industriels régulateurs et
s'appuyer sur des financements européens
afin que nous puissions être rendez vous
de l'innovation de la production et de
la livraison de produits de santé en
ordre nous avons aussi échangé sur les
nouvelles commandes de la commission
européenne auprès de pfizer et moderna
et appelé à accélérer les livraisons en
cours tout comme les négociations pour
les futurs vaccins tout particulièrement
pour ce qui concerne le laboratoire
novavax evans neva l'approchent
européenne vous le savez je la défends
parce que c'est le seul moyen
d'organiser une campagne vaccinale
efficaces en europe et elle porte ses
fruits
nous avons pu nous appuyer sur plusieurs
types de vaccins avec différentes
technologies pour que tous les états
membres puissent déployer leur stratégie
de vaccination de manière parallèle
depuis fin décembre
partir en ordre dispersé aurait été
inutile
nous le voyons aujourd'hui alors que la
problématique des variants est ressentie
précisément partout en europe
notre objectif est de sécuriser les
commandes passées de continuer à
produire davantage en europe mais nous
avons encore vu cette semaine l'annoncé
de plusieurs laboratoires qui ont
accepté de convertir des sites de
production pour produire des vaccins
existants et homologué
et de préparer la production future à
cet égard nous avons également un
échange sur le renforcement de la
production sur le sol européen en
identifiant les capacités encore
disponibles de certains industriels qui
pourrait aider à la production du vaccin
et d'autres produits de santé la
poursuite aussi des vaccins de deuxième
génération qui arriveront à l'automne
ainsi que l'identification de nombreuses
nos besoins en termes d'intrants avec
des cartographies très clair je veux à
cet égard remercié la commission pour le
travail important qui a été réalisé ces
dernières semaines sur ce sujet par la
présidente van der leyen et la dass
force piloté par le commissaire breton
avec une équipe dédiée l'union
européenne se met en capacité de
produire comme l'a dit la commission
européenne de manière beaucoup plus
autonomes à partir de la fin d'année et
de manière durable car il est
vraisemblable que nous aurons à vivre
avec ce virus dans la durée et donc à
poursuivre des campagnes vaccinales
il faudra renforcer précisément cette
autonomie européenne il nous faut aussi
disposer d'une information transparente
sur ce que les entreprises basées en
europe produisent et exportent c'est
l'objet du mécanisme de contrôle et
d'autorisation des exportations que nous
avons souhaité poursuivre je suis
attirer l'attention sur l'importance
d'avoir un mécanisme comparables sur
l'ensemble des composants pour les
vaccins mais aussi les traitements ou
les diagnostics ces variants donc
doivent nous conduire à la plus grande
vigilance et coordination en particulier
avec nos voisins je l' ai rappelé des
mesures de contrôle peuvent être
nécessaires à certaines frontières
internes à l'union européenne en
particulier pour combattre la
propagation des variants mais le
principe général doit rester celui de la
préservation des mouvements des
frontaliers des transporteurs tout
simplement pour éviter de fragmenter les
bassins de vie et de rompre les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
nous pouvons concilier là
cohérence de nos vies avec la lutte
contre le virus et la diffusion des
vrais cette même unité coordination sont
nécessaires s'agissant des certificats
de vaccination pour y revenir dans les
questions si vous souhaitez ces
certificats sont à distinguer des
mécanismes que nous sommes en train de
préparer chacun dans nos pays
ils permettront simplement une fois les
campagnes vaccinales fait dans l'union
européenne de réorganiser la circulation
entre états membres de manière plus
fluide
je comprends à cet égard l'espoir de
retour à une vie normale que ce site le
développement d'un tel outil
mais là aussi nous devons trouver un
équilibre nous devons éviter que chaque
pays développe son propre système et
donc travailler à une certification
médicale commune et dans le même temps
alors que nos populations n'ont pas
encore toutes eu accès aux varie au
vaccin qui est administrée sur une base
de rappel volontaire et pour le moment
avec des critères d'âge un tel document
ne saurait ouvrir des droits spécifiques
aux personnes vaccinées
il ya donc des questions sanitaires mais
également éthiques juridiques
importantes sur lesquelles nous devons
travailler dans les prochains mois enfin
et c'est un point sur lequel je suis
longuement revenue l'europe doit prendre
toute sa part dans la solidarité
internationale pour lutter efficacement
contre cette pandémie mondiale
il ya un an nous avions lancé
l'initiative acte à solidarité pour
l'afrique et il est clair que nous avons
besoin de pâtir cette solidarité à
l'égard de nos voisins qu'il s'agisse
des balkans de l'afrique en particulier
cette solidarité elle repose sur une
aide sanitaire pour les vaccins les
traitements le diagnostic le soutien au
système de santé primaires la production
aussi de l'ensemble de ses matériels
mais également un soutien économique
comme nous avons déjà commencé à le
faire comme
continuons le faire sur ce qui est des
vaccins j'ai eu l'occasion de défendre
l'idée portée par la france
angers7 la semaine dernière et de
répondre ce faisant un appel que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie et l'union africaine et le
parlement européens nous ont appelés
aujourd'hui
en effet nous ne vaincrons durablement
ce virus que si nous parvenons à
développer une campagne de vaccination
partout sur la planète et en particulier
chez nos voisins et amis africains nous
le savons il ya 6 5 millions de
soignants sur le continent africain
ce qui signifie mobilisé 13 millions de
doses ces doses représente 0 points 43 %
de celles qui ont été commandés par
l'union européenne les états unis le
canada le japon
c'est un effort minime mais qui doit
pouvoir s'organiser dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois
c'est ce sur quoi nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sans que cela vienne d'ailleurs
perturbé en quoi que ce soit nos
campagnes de vaccination domestique
cette solidarité est extrêmement
importante et sera la condition de
crédibilité du mécanisme du mécanisme
dit kovacs nous reprendrons donc demain
matin aux travaux sur deux thématiques
également importante celle de l'europe
de la défense est celle de notre
voisinage sud sur l'europe de la défense
nous l'avons rappelé le 5 février avec
la chancelière merkel nous devons
continuer à travailler au renforcement
de notre analyse collective des menaces
et de nos capacités
c'est ce à quoi doit contribuer le
nouveau projet de boussole stratégique
initiée par la présidence allemande du
conseil et qui devrait se clore sous
présidence française au premier semestre
depuis 2017 nous avons fait faire
beaucoup de chemin cette europe de la
défense avec la coopération structurée
permanente avec certains états le
lancement du fonds européen de défense
de la facilité européenne pour la paix
du lancement de l'initiative européenne
d'intervention nous avons structuré
quelque chose de profondément nouveau et
qui d'ailleurs va se décliner aussi à
travers des coopérations a dû
riel mais également une plus grande
souveraineté technologique nous ouvrons
à présent un nouveau chapitre qui doit
nous aider à nous projeter à l'horizon
2030 pour adapter nos opérations aux
défis actuels et anticiper les nouvelles
formes de menaces cyber maritime
spatiale aérienne et c'est seulement
poursuivant sur cette voie que l'europe
pourra prendre sa juste part dans la
sécurité collective être un allié fiable
et crédible notamment à travers le
pilier européen de l'otan
enfin nous aborderons le sujet de notre
coopération avec nos partenaires majeurs
au sein du voisinage sud dans cet espace
partagé qu'est la méditerranée la
commission a proposé récemment un nouvel
agenda commun pour que nous puissions
investir conjointement jusqu'à 7
milliards d'euros pour la période 2021
et 2027
nous devons nous saisir de ce nouveau
programme pour apporter notre appui à la
jeunesse de ces pays aux investissements
dans les technologies vertes au dialogue
entre nos sociétés civiles
c'est pourquoi il était important aussi
que les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
puisse discuter ensemble de ses
perspectives ambitieuses avec nos
voisins du sud de la méditerranée
et vous savez combien je tiens et croit
aussi à ce format le sommet des deux
rives aura vocation d'ailleurs à
décliner l'agenda français et européens
en la matière en impliquant profondément
les sociétés civiles voilà les quelques
mots que je souhaitais partager avec
vous ce soir à l'issue de cette première
partie du conseil européen et avant de
répondre à vos questions ce présent
après une première question de virginie
malingre du monde s'il vous plaît
oui bonsoir je voulais revenir sur le
mécanisme de contrôle d'exportation de
la vigne en passe ou les arts sont déjà
ils avaient honte son objectif qui était
à l'époque de voir si effectivement
astrazeneca avait ou non
exporter des doses de vaccin en dehors
de l'union européenne des doses qui
aurait dû être réservé à l'union
européenne
est-ce que ça a confirmé les soupçons
que qui était né à cette époque
deuxièmement je voulais voir si vous
avez décidé ou discuté ce soir de
transformer de le rendre peut-être
dur pour les entreprises qui ne
respectent pas leurs engagements ou si
vous avez testé juste de lancer le débat
à savoir comment faire alors c'est un
mécanisme qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre quand il a été proposé par la
présidente sandaré m je le soutiens pour
ma part parce qu'il nous permet tout
simplement de nous assurer que les
contrats qui ont été signés sont honorés
et dont il ya des engagements qui ont
été pris de livraisons de doses aux
européens il faut qu'il soit honoré avec
les bons volumes et les bonnes dates
dans un contexte où comme je le disais
nous mobilisons le maximum de nos
implantations au service d'ailleurs des
vaccins qui ont d'ores et déjà été
retenues pour ne prendre l'exemple de
sanofi un site a été converti en
allemagne pour produire du bio ntech
riser est un site est en train d'être
convertie en france pour produire donc
dû johnson & johnson quand il fera
homologues
donc c'est un c'est un mécanisme qui
nous permet de nous assurer que ces
contrats sont honorés de pouvoir auditer
les entreprises et nous assurer que les
doses qui sont réservées à l'europe sont
bien versé c'est aussi un mécanisme de
pression quand les contrats ne sont pas
honorés mais qu'on va honorer les
contrats avec d'autres ce qui a parfois
pu être le cas donc il est utile il est
légitime surtout quand je vois les
mécanismes qui existent en chine aux
états unis
maintenant est ce qu'il faut pour autant
pas ce que j'entends le débat monte en
faire un mécanisme d'interdiction des
exports non très clairement il est tout
à fait vrai que sur des sites de
production européens des doses sont
produites qui vont vers d'autres
géographies non européennes et je veux
simplement vous rappeler que nous mêmes
nous importons des doses qui sont faites
sur d'autres continents
why ou hors de l'union européenne
beaucoup de ce que nous avons consommé
en astrazeneca sont venus de grande
bretagne
nous avons importé des doses qu'ils
avaient été fabriqués aux états unis et
pour beaucoup de vaccins ce sera le cas
d'avoir importé des doses de moderna qui
n'étaient pas faites sur le sol européen
nous sommes en train de construire afin
de construire le finaliser les accords
qui permettront de faire ce qu'on
appelle le film finish par exemple pour
moderne
donc je crois qu'il faut éviter la
fragmentation d'une production mondiale
ça c'est un point donc je ne suis pas
favorable à ce que chacun fasse ou du
nationalisme vaccinale our fragmente les
choses mais je suis pour une stratégie
de coopération et de transparence et ce
mécanisme il sert à avoir la
transparence à l'égard de nos
concitoyens et vis-à-vis des
laboratoires à mettre une saine pression
ce qui est important maintenant c'est
que tous les laboratoires qui se sont
engagés sur des calendriers et
déversements d'eau soit au rendez-vous
des engagements qu'ils ont pris
d'abord parce que c'est un engagement
contractuel et c'est important soit
ensuite parce que dans le contexte
sanitaire
c'est un engagement à l'égard de la
santé de nos populations
donc voilà comment nous l'utilisons
aujourd'hui ce qui a été acté
aujourd'hui c'est de le poursuivre il
n'y a pas de consensus à ce stade pour
le renforcer comme je voulais dit je
pense que le risque serait grand que ce
soit contre productif maintenant moi
j'ai demandé aussi à ce qu'on regarde la
possibilité d'avoir de tels mécanismes
sur les différentes composantes je le
disais des vaccins des traitements et
autres et c'est très important qu'on ait
un dialogue permanent et de coopération
avec les états unis d'amérique
parce que évidemment ce que nous voulons
éviter c'est une situation ou tel ou tel
continent que telle ou telle puissance
en viendrait en effet à bloquer ses
exports parce que là je pense que ce
serait grave et contre productif mais
nous n'aurions pas les moyens de réagir
donc voila nous nous équipons nous nous
organisons nous pérennisons ce système
mais il n'est en aucun cas un mécanisme
qui doit bloquer les exportations
c'est un mécanisme de transparence de
contrôle de vérité une question non oui
birginie mais alors vous êtes sur nuke
on vous entend plus virgin et à la vous
n'entendez oui très bien oui s'est
désolé vous n'avez pas vraiment répondu
à ma question de manière intentionnelle
mais malines il fait savoir
le mécanisme nous a permis de savoir si
astrazeneca avait ou non respecté ses
engagements à savoir sk strobl mika a
envoyé en dehors de l'europe des doses
qui était normalement réservé à nora
j'ai répondu de manière générique mais
je peux illustré avec astrazeneca
il est tout à fait vrai qu'astrazeneca a
envoyé des doses produites en europe
vers d'autres marchés
aussi vrai que d'ailleurs failli there
but ventech envoie des doses qui sont
produites en europe vers d'autres
marchés est aussi vrai que nous avons
nous même reçu des 12 qui n'était pas
produit dans l'union européenne par par
exemple astrazeneca pour le marché
européen qui était normalement non sans
faire un désaveu marché interne la
difficulté ensuite de nous et
laboratoires c'est de gérer le goulot
d'étranglement qui sont en production
donc aujourd'hui ce que nous nous avons
dix astrazeneca c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
honoré de manière exacte leur dernière
livraison
donc nous avons un dialogue qui est
menée par la commission européenne et la
task force pour leur dire ça ne va pas
ce qui a fait que d'ailleurs on a eu des
discussions sur des doses qui devaient
être exportés qui touchent évidemment
d'autres pays qui les avait commencé et
donc ces doses n'ont pas pu être libre
et être livré en temps mais on leur a
dit que vous n'êtes pas sérieux dans les
engagements que vous avez pris puisque
n'est pas au rendez vous de vos
engagements avec l'europe
donc je simplement dissocier les deux
questions c'est tout à fait normal
qu'ils aient des doses qu'ils soient
produites en europe comme ailleurs et
que des doses produites ailleurs à et en
europe
c'est ce que je vous disais de manière
générique c'est vrai pour astrazeneca
c'est vrai pour pfizer
ce sera vrai pour les autres parce que
c'est comme ça que ça marche
c'est comme ça que les structures et la
production pharmaceutique par contre il
est tout à fait vrai que pour le cas
d'astrazeneca
il y à des retards aujourd'hui et donc
nous mettons la pression pour que ces
retards soient comblées et pour que nous
ayons un échéancier précis respecter
maintenant de jérôme grivet de la fp je
crois monsieur bonsoir
on s'en remettant dès qu'on ne verra pas
ce qu'il est sur son portable d'agir on
t'écoute
oui voilà alors je voulais revenir sur
le certificat vaccinale est ce que vous
êtes parvenus à un accord entre vous
pour une entrée et une mise en oeuvre
d'ici les vacances de l'été et sur le
plan national
où en est votre réflexion et est ce que
pour lui préciser ce que ça veut dire
quand vous dites de tels documents ne
saurait couvrir de droits spécifiques
aux personnes vaccinées mais merci alors
je les distinguer deux types de
mécanismes pas ce qu'il ya dans le débat
public je sens qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion parfois sur ce sujet il ya
d'abord la réflexion qu'on doit tout
savoir sur ce que j'appellerais un pass
sanitaires et ça c'est quelque chose je
tiendrai d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine
une une réunion sur ce sujet avec les
membres du gouvernement nous devons
préparer organiser la réouverture des
structures quand ce sera possible
contexte ne se permet pas aujourd'hui
mais les musées les salles de spectacle
les restaurants les lieux de
convivialité les festivals évidemment il
est vrai il est évident que pour
organiser ces réouvertures on va tout
faire pour protéger en même temps la
population et protéger aussi les
professionnels et donc nous allons
mettre en place une organisation à
travers ce que j'appellerais un pass
sanitaire c'est à dire on va demander à
ce que d'abord les gens sans registre
pour faciliter vous savez le système d'
alerte c'est à dire que si quelqu'un est
venu un tel événement dans un lieu
public qu'ils puissent est enregistré
avec un code la manière la plus simple
la plus numérique qui soit et qu'on
puisse lui non seulement qu'ils puissent
alerter de manière automatique mais
qu'on puisse retrouver beaucoup plus
facilement c'est qu'à contacter ce qu'on
commence à faire depuis au moins tous
antico vide dans le fram manière
beaucoup plus efficace sans doute on
pourra intégrer des éléments de test
négatif récents on demande dans beaucoup
de situations d'avoir des tests de 48 ou
72 heures qui vous met négatif ça peut
être aussi un instrument ou pourra
regarder aussi
si vous avez été vaccinées je vais pas
ici présentés sujet mais c'est un sujet
important pour permettre de ré ouvrir
ces lieux qui va poser beaucoup de
questions techniques de respect des
données individuelles d'organisation de
liberté de nos libertés
donc il faut préparer dès maintenant
techniquement politiquement
juridiquement sujet et ça ce sera dans
nos pays pour la réouverture de beaucoup
d'activités
j'attire tout de suite l'attention sur
le fait que quand je dis pas sanitaire
c'est que ça ne peut pas être soumis au
vaccin
parce que si on arrive à un moment dans
le printemps à rouvrir certains de ces
lieux
nous ne saurions conditionné leur accès
à une vaccination alors même que nous
n'aurions même pas ouvert la vaccination
aux plus jeunes d'entre nous serait
invraisemblable
donc faut pas le lier au vaccin c'est
plus complexe que ça c'est un ensemble
qui permettra de mieux tester
d'identifier les gens et d'utiliser son
hôte aussi les tests une palette je puis
dire d'instruments ça c'est pour chacun
de nos pays pour organiser la
réouverture de notre de nos activités et
au fond pour être encore plus précis
dans notre capacité à tester alerté
protéger on rouvre et en utilisant
toutes les je dirais les potentialités
qui nous sont offertes à ce moment à
côté de ça nous avons un débat européen
qui lui est un débat sur la libre
circulation entre les pays en
particulier pour préparer la saison
estivale à un moment donc là quand lula
campagne de vaccination sera plus avancé
premier ministre et ministre de la santé
tout à leur ont redonné d'ailleurs des
objectifs et des perspectives pour l'été
à cet égard et donc il est légitime que
nous nous organisions parce
qu'aujourd'hui la circulation est
possible quand il ya des tensions entre
régions mais des des contraintes de
tests vous l'avez eue récemment par
exemple entre plusieurs régions
frontalières dont certaines régions là
si frontalière france allemagne mais ça
a été vrai de plusieurs autres
frontières en europe et donc nous aurons
un moment à organiser la réouverture la
libre circulation vers des lieux de
tourisme à l'été est donc là nous
préparons ce qu'on a appelé justement
7,7 cette stratégie d'ensemble et ses
certificats de vaccination c'est le
terme qui est aujourd'hui retenu au
niveau européen c'est un mandat qu'on a
donné à la commission en décembre
dernier il ya donc une équipe qui a été
constitué avec les meilleurs
scientifiques et régulateurs également
au niveau européen et qui a pour but
d'harmoniser les pratiques et là aussi
si je puis dire de lever des questions
qui sont au fond très technique
donc c'est pas la question n'est pas un
accord politique on a donné le mandat en
décembre
c'est de lever des questions techniques
avec la perspective est la volonté que
ce soit prêt à l'été quelles sont ces
questions pour vous donner quelques
illustrations la des rues de l'immunité
vaccinale
aujourd'hui on se fait vacciner en
europe mais il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
consensus scientifique établie pour
savoir quel est votre durée d'immunité
quand vous avez été la cible il ya des
données qui ont été transmises par des
laboratoires pfizer ventech mais nos
autorités n'ont pas aujourd'hui certifié
que ça dure et en deux semaines tant de
mois il faut évidemment l'intégrer pour
donner un passeport
quelqu'un s'est fait vacciner et est
considérée comme plus totalement emule
si quelqu'un s'est fait vaccinés avec un
vaccin qui n'est pas homologué pour
qu'on puisse le savoir
donc ça c'est des questions très très
sanitaires et techniques
il ya évidemment entre pays européens
également des questions éthiques des
questions juridiques à régler et en
particulier cette même question pour
notre jeunesse parce que ce ce
certificat de vaccination ne doit pas
être si je puis dire une condition ça
doit nous aider à organiser des libre
mouvement
mais là aussi je pense à nos jeunes moi
je n'accepterai pas un système où en
quelque sorte en conditionne l'accès à
tel ou tel pays un tel certificat nos
jeunes n'auront pas été vaccinés fin
juin début juillet a pas leur dire vous
pouvez pas circuler d'une région à
l'autre
en aucun cas parce que vous avez pas le
certificat de vaccination donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faudra là aussi avoir des
stratégies de tests de protection ou
autre voilà cent des réflexions qui ne
sont pas pour maintenant mais il faut
prévoir demain il faut nous coordonner
lever tous ces sujets et donc voyez ces
réflexions dans le pays il ya cette
réflexion européenne à travers le
certificat de vaccination qui
aujourd'hui est un chantier technique
qui est menée donc par ses équipes
compétentes sur la base du mandat que
nous avons donné en décembre
est ce qu'on appelle le heal health
network qui justement travail sur tous
ces sujets de raymond tu as de politico
l'on sort monsieur le président je vous
avais parlé de solidarité on a vu passer
une demande de la part de la république
tchèque est aussi je pense de la
slovaquie pour emprunter des doses à
l'ensemble des pays européens
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose que je
ne comprends pas dans cette demande
parce que d'après ce qu'on nous avait
expliqué tous les pays membres ont eu
accès à la même procédure pour réserver
leur dose en même temps nous qu'est ce
qui se passe du côté tchèque et slovaque
est ce que vous avez décidé de ce que
vous allez faire ce que la france
donnera l'exemple et deuxièmement on
voit beaucoup de réticences en ce moment
dans certains pays européens envers le
vaccin astrazeneca donc les deux
existent les gens ne viennent pas à leur
rendez vous est ce que quand votre tour
viendra
si on vous propose de faire vacciner à
astrazeneca vous le ferez vous même
merci merci beaucoup
ce premier sujet je ne faut pas
confondre le sujet solidarités
international acta et autres et les
sujets de répartition des doses en
europe
je vais tâcher de vous expliquer comment
cette situation est possible nous avons
eu un mécanisme d'achat européen
régulier par la commission qui a passé
contrat et qui en a pas c'est aussi sur
les candidats vaccins à venir elle a
d'ailleurs complété sa avec des achats
supplémentaires on l'a vu cette semaine
encore sur modern la répartition ensuite
est fait
paris passe une entre tous les états
membres avec un critère de population et
donc à chaque fois que les deux arrivées
les que ce critère de répartition a été
activé certains pays en fin d'année
dernière n'ont pas souhaité appeler une
partie de leur dose ils n'ont pas
saturer leur côté pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il n'était pas persuadé que les
en particulier les plaisirs modern
arrêter les projets les plus efficaces
avait été mal connue à l'époque
conditions de conservation et de
logistique plus dur est donc ils ont un
peu saoul commandé à dessin c'est un
choix que ces pays ont fait ces doses
qu'ils n'étaient pas à louer on fait
ensuite l'objet d'un mécanisme
d'allocation par la commission
européenne qui a permis de repasser dans
un tour et qui a permis donc à des états
en quelque sorte de surcotiser et
d'avoir plus de doses que le prorata de
leur population
nous sommes plusieurs à l'avoir fait la
france l'a fait c'est ce qui fait que si
vous prenez le stricts critères nous
avons un peu plus de doses que nos
populations l'allemagne le danemark
plusieurs beaucoup beaucoup des youyous
et aujourd'hui la quasi totalité de ces
pays qui à l'époque on souhaite les
landes aux reviennent en disant vas nous
voudrions pouvoir récupérer et donc je
suis tout à fait prêt à ce que des
mécanismes de solidarité qui se met en
place en tout cas de péréquation à
nouveau j'ai dit que nous nous prendrons
vraiment me font nous serons au rendez
vous de nos responsabilités on peut pas
dire on croit à l'europe et quand
quelqu'un est en difficulté ne pas y
répondre
donc je suis très solidaire de nos
voisins mais je pense que c'est à la
commission de proposer un mécanisme qui
soit soutenable et qui donne
clarté visibilité transparence à tout le
monde donc c'est comme ça qu'on réglera
le sujet sur astrazeneca
moi je pense que je vais avoir un
message clair tous les vaccins qui sont
aujourd'hui proposés à notre population
ce sont des vaccins qui ont fait l'objet
d'une homologation par l'autorité
européenne du médicament qui ensuite ont
été revus par la haute autorité de santé
qui a donné donc des préconisations très
précises après c'est vrai qu'on à chaque
semaine des annonces des nouvelles et
que la science continue de progresser en
temps réel ce qui peut parfois perturbé
et certains de nos concitoyens et donc
je simplement dire nous avons les règles
de sécurité sanitaire les plus
exigeantes au monde
nous européens il ya cette double
homologation ce qui fait que parfois
certains vaccins qui sont acceptées par
d'autres ne sont pas pris chine donc
vraiment le maximum de sécurité est
apportée au vu des dernières
publications scientifiques l'efficacité
tels que nous les avons positionné la
campagne vaccinale d'astrazeneca est
avérée et là dessus moi je m'en remets
au professeur fisher que le gouvernement
a mandaté pour diriger natation
assassinat l'équipe qui plus est relays
parole scientifique pas un sujet
politique vous savez moi je suis sur les
vaccins extrêmement il ya de la
diplomatie et de la politique quand il
faut commander à louer les deux produits
ressasser je dirais la part du travail
qui revient aux dirigeants pour ce qui
est ensuite du reste pour moi c'est un
critère de transparence et donc toute la
transparence soit faite sur astrazeneca
ce vaccin à ces critères il est sécurisé
selon les critères de nos autorités
sanitaires il a son efficacité telle que
de manière transparente affiché donc je
pense qu'il est tout à fait utile et
doit être administré mon tour viendra et
j'ai quand même le temps donc moi si
c'est si ce vaccin qui m'est proposé je
le prendrai bien évidemment alors après
ils sont en train d'affiner aussi les
choses sur personnes qui ont eu le virus
et qui ont encore d antiques
donc je mens je respecterai aussi des
directives qui me seront donnés moi je
tiens à ce que l'ensemble des dirigeants
se fasse comme le reste de la population
donc je me ferai vacciner quand le
moment viendra de ma tranche d'âge si je
puis dire et avec le protocole qui
vaudra si j'ai encore des anticorps une
question daniel naud ce boom de
bloomberg
tania vous entend pas
alors est ce que vous arrivez à vous
connecter il n'y a pas ailleurs il a par
ailleurs plus d'autres questions donc si
anja n'arrive pas à se connecter
alors dernier dernière tentative
dernière tentative est-ce que anja tu
veux poser ta question par écrit
peut-être
elle va écrire
alors nous allons avant la question par
écrit
alors entre temps il ya une question de
marie chanterai tf1 lci marie alors
c'est une question collective bonjour
monsieur le président bonsoir monsieur
le président vous marier en bienvenue
dans les locaux tf1 vous faisait parler
des articles cas de vaccination et de la
coordination européenne n'accepterait
pas que les jeunes ne puissent pas
voyagé notamment cet été
on voit cependant certains pays ont
décidé de faire cavalier seul on pense
notamment à la presse ou à retrouver
nordiques qui sont en train d'installer
petit à petit ce certificat qu'est ce
qui pourrait faire que cette
coordination européenne fonctionne à
défaut par exemple skype jeunes et sur
les frontières avec parfois certaines
initiatives assez personnel par exemple
de l'allemagne non vous savez j'avais
raison c'est pour ça qu'on s'y prend
suffisamment tôt d'abord il ya des pays
qui sont très dépendants du tourisme et
qui ont à coeur de très vite construire
des solutions organisationnelles qui
permettront de réserver des vacances
d'été quand tout ira mieux et en toute
sécurité pour donner de la visibilité à
un secteur économique
ces cas d'agathe moi je respecte tout à
fait ça simplement il faut que ça se
fasse dans un cadre européen homologué
sinon on recréera collectivement de même
difficulté et donc on c'est pour ça
qu'il faut qu'on se coordonnent alors
vous avez raison il ya des initiatives
au stade où nous sommes d'ailleurs on
n'est qu'un et fin février
nous sommes plutôt tous sous la pression
d'un virus et de ses variantes qui sont
très présents très agressive dans nos
pays
donc la grande différence par rapport à
ce que vous évoquez qui a parfois été je
dirais le la tension qui peut exister
entre les uns et des autres qui avait
été sous qui avait existé l'année
dernière
je comprends maintenant on arrive à
mieux coordonner
je pense que la grande différence c'est
que là on anticipe c'est que ces
certificats cette organisation ça n'est
pas pour demain
c'est pour cet été et donc ce qui est
impératif c'est de regarder ce que les
uns et les autres font de nous inspirer
d'ailleurs des exemples les plus
innovants mais de définir des standards
communs parce que de manière très claire
nous avons une liberté de circulation
entre nos frontières si les choses vont
mieux
aucun d'entre nous n'a acceptera que
pour capter par exemple des touristes y
un pays qu'ils soient moins disant que
l'autre et qui prennent des risques en
faisant venir des gens du bout du monde
pour remplir ses hôtels donc on aura un
minimum commun pour des gens qui
viendront hors de l'union européenne
voudra tous avoir la même règle pour
nous pour nous protéger parce qu'on aura
demandé pendant des mois des efforts à
nos populations et l inverse on voudra
absolument tous protéger nos jeunesse
parce qu'on en sera à peu près au même
niveau de progression de nos campagnes
vaccinales
donc je pense que j'ai bon espoir que on
soit coordonnée je ne pense pas que ce
sera la même chose que pour la gestion
des frontières parce qu'on s'y prend
beaucoup plus tôt mais il faut s'y
prendre maintenant pour que ce soit
coordonné en bonne fin à l'été parce que
c'est un sujet compliqué avec je lisais
des enjeux sanitaires économiques
éthiques et juridiques la question kenya
pause par question et par écrit par an
est très similaire à celle de d'alison
dans l'hypothèse d'un état européen
prendrait cette initiative de manière
unilatérale
elle donc de discriminer aux frontières
en fonction du vaccin par exemple si la
grèce met en place un tel système que
ferait la france peut-on exiger des
mesures de rétorsion des mesures de
quarantaine d'entreprendre
on n'en est pas du tout là je pense que
c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour dire cela
aucun pays d'europe de profession a
déployé une stratégie vaccinale qui
permet de faire ça et aucun de leurs
afférentes
man de l'été il faut être très sérieux
c'est à dire que nous nous sommes en
train de vacciner les plus âgées et les
personnels soignants
donc on peut pas à fond peut pas du tout
en faire une condition de développement
donc je pense qu'il faut absolument
il faut pas confondre ce qu'ils sont des
positions fortes expliqué par certains
pays à leurs acteurs économiques et une
juste préparation qui va prendre des
mois donc je pense qu'il faut calmer ce
débat il faut l'expliquer pour que tout
le monde se projette lui expliquer
comment on va faire dans nos pays
comment nous allons faire au niveau
européen préparé techniquement mais nous
aurons à la fin une approche harmonisée
européenne
c'est évident parce qu'elle pas d'autres
possibilités et c'est l'intérêt de tous
donc je préfère pas qu'on rentre dans
des tout de suite des logiques de
rétorsion de la politique fiction
on va travailler ensemble on trouvera
les bonnes solutions t il ya plus de
questions merci beaucoup moi ce que vous
invitez la souhaite un bon courage ils
veulent fourrer merci